now it is results day in england wales
and northern ireland with a level
students
finding out if they made the grade
though many will find themselves
disappointed
as one in three will find their results
have been marked down
in the absence of exams pupils in
england will get to choose from three
options to determine their results the
first option for students is to accept
the calculated grades given to them
today
but if their mock grades were higher
pupils have the choice to
upgrade their results to the better mark
they'll have to go through an appeals
process and their school will need to
submit evidence before the mock results
can be used and then there is this third
option in this so-called triple
lock students who are unhappy with their
results
can sit exams in the autumn to try and
get a better grade
and we're being told that gcse students
are being given the same guarantee
with their grades and of course those
results for them will be coming out
next week
now you have been sending in your
questions about this year's exam results
all day and i'm pleased to say i am
joined by
two-thirds of our panel of experts to
help answer those questions deborah
humphries the vice chancellor of the
university of brighton
we're expecting mary kern cook the
former chief executive of ucas to join
us
and we are joined by natasha devon a
trustee of the mental health charities
student mind so very warm welcome
to you both thanks for joining us so
listen let's start with you deborah
humphries of course an incredibly
stressful day
for students but also for universities
because of these last minute changes
there has been
a great deal of uncertainty hasn't there
uh hello and um delighted to to
contribute
there has been a considerable degree of
uncertainty in the last 24-48 hours
um but i'm really pleased that uh as
ever higher education and certainly the
university of brighton
has a flexible approach it's mindful
that actually for
students for our applicants this
is the most stressful time for them and
we're here
we're open we're flexible and we're
here to listen we're here to help them
on their journey so
my major message to all applicants is no
matter what the situation please don't
panic
your universities are here waiting to
help you so
we will do everything we can in what is
an extraordinary set of circumstances
it is extraordinary isn't it and natasha
i will come to you in a second but i
want to kick off with this first
question
from matt which uh goes to you deborah
and how do
i and i know this is a difficult
question to answer the question from
matt is how do i appeal a grade
will i definitely get my mock grade or
is there still
some doubt so
good question matt and i only wish i
could give you greater certainty
so at the moment we're all waiting to
hear from off qual
about what the process would be for
appeals at the moment i
probably know as much as you do matt
about what that process would be
i know that ofqua have committed to
making that available
literally within the next few days so
please watch them
watch them the first step is to do this
through your school or your college
that's the really key route at this
stage have that conversation with your
school or college
and certainly the feedback we've been
having through social media is that lots
of people have been speaking to their
schools about how they appeal
and the schools don't know but obviously
with these last minute changes
uh off call only finding out yesterday
we do understand these are
unprecedented times listen i'm pleased
to say mary kernuk cook joins us the
former chief executive
of ucas thanks very much for joining our
clinic this afternoon we've just been
discussing
what an incredibly unique set of
circumstances
uh students are facing this year just
before i go into any of the viewers
questions uh just a question to you mary
if
if you'll indulge me on whether you
think that
the government sort of calibration
process has been a good one
look i think um as with so many things
uh with this corona crisis
um lots of things have gone wrong for
everybody and gosh haven't they gone
wrong
for people taking exams this year
um unfortunately there is just no way
that you can have 100
fair process when people haven't
actually
sat down in front of their exam papers
and shown what they can do
on the day so yeah i feel very
sympathetic to students but i also feel
sympathetic to the off qual and the
government and the regulators because i
i don't think there was ever a perfect
solution for this and
and i think one of my pieces of advice
would be try not to take it too
personally because
um it isn't you know a piece of exam
answer paper that a student has written
that is connected to their grade
it's a combination of pieces of data
from the
from the school and the moderation
process that the regulators have done
and things will have gone wrong on an
individual basis and i feel really
sorry for those people but um the advice
to get to your school or college and
appeal if you think something has gone
wrong
uh is the best possible advice well
let's dip into
some of the questions then that we've
had from our viewers and our followers
on twitter and we've just chosen this
one from ellen but natasha this
represents
a whole tranche of really similar
messages to be perfectly honest uh ellen
wrote
during lockdown i struggled with my
mental health and i have got downgraded
results
how can i now motivate myself to revise
and to cope with
autumn resets
well i think the first thing to say is
that pretty much everyone that i have
spoken to
and that's a lot of people have in some
way
struggled with their mental health
throughout lockdown because
if you're not feeling anxious if you're
not feeling a bit low
right now it's probably because you're
not paying attention
you know people keep saying that it's
unprecedented circumstances for a reason
but having struggled with mental health
difficulties myself what i will say is
that
each time i've had to learn a new
technique to
cope i have another weapon in my arsenal
that helps me to be more resilient
and also helps me to learn better or to
focus better on my work
so try and see this blip that you've had
with your mental health as an
opportunity it's taught you something
about your mind and how it works and you
can apply that
when you go back to your studies and i
would also say check out student space
and that's studentsbase.org dot uk
that's been set up by student minds and
it's
a whole hub that students in england and
wales can access and there's
loads of advice on there on how to
support yourself with your mental health
okay natasha fantastic stuff and this
next question for you deborah and it's
in relation to
what the government has been asking
universities to do in terms of
after being understanding of the
situation and giving
a little bit of lenience to students and
allowing appeals processes to go through
perhaps holding
those places open this is from lucy and
and echoing much of what
uh my previous question just asked
natasha you know what happens
she asks if i perform worse in my autumn
resets i'm worried i won't be able to
teach myself the content
natasha's really important point i'm
thinking and this also
leads to lucy's question as well i mean
at universities we
are really focused on how students make
that transition
from and for many students not having
been in school for
six months how you make that transition
to university so certainly in brighton
we have a longer brighton scheme which
is
bringing people in making them feel part
of the community early
that transition into the first year of
undergraduate studies
is really important now in terms of
lucy's specifics about
an appeal i would again say talk to your
school about the appeal process
but talk to your university we're all
here
waiting to talk to you listening to you
we will focus on individual
circumstances so lucy please talk to the
university which is your first choice
all the others you have on your list
we're all
trying to do the very best for you um i
just want to pick up now with mary
kernot cook
um there have been allegations leveled
at the government of inequality
and of chaos today that children from
um disadvantaged or low-performing
schools
are coming off worse today and i don't
know if you saw the
former education minister um ed balls
tweeting saying how could education
ministers and senior officials possibly
not have spotted
that giving greater weight to teacher
assessment in smaller cohorts sick forms
would bias results towards private
schools and against
large sixth form colleges it's beyond
belief and i just
wonder what your assessment of that is
yeah i haven't seen anything but a few
snippets of the
of the data yet um and
uh and of course this was very much what
we saw unfolding in scotland
last week um and i i i'm not sure where
the
where the date is published but what
what is interesting is that the
data published by ucas today about who's
got into university
actually shows that the number of
applicants or
students from um poorer communities have
actually
the entry rate has grown faster than
some of
the more affluent students so it isn't
kind of playing out in terms of
university entrance
um to be to be honest i would be
astonished if there hadn't been
um very careful equalities work done
on the methodology for this and i was
just about to start reading
um a long technical document from off
call about it which which may reveal
more
um so uh i i just don't have the
information at the moment but i'd be
astonished if this wasn't on
um ministers and officials radars
uh you know right from the start okay
and perhaps you can help with this next
question if not deborah humphries
i'm hoping you can at this from tim
who's a parent
he messaged into us at sky news to say
how do the center-assessed grades
actually work
and why are these different to the final
result
lots of confused folk out there
yes it's a it's a it's a really
difficult one i mean the center of
assessed grades is the teachers sitting
down and making their best estimate of
what they thought each
student would get um so so let's say for
example
there were five students in one class
who they thought would get a grade b
in a particular subject and that's what
they would
put on the assessment and but they also
have to rank those students so they have
to say which of those five with a b
is the best student and which is the
second and third and so on and so
when the regulator has done the
statistical
uh moderation of all these results they
will have used that
ranking um that's that placement
that the teachers have used as well as
the center assessed grade and kind of
fed that into their statistical model
in order to come up with the uh with the
awarded grade
and the other thing just to note is i
could just imagine if i were a teacher
and i was trying to think you know if a
student was maybe
borderline b or c you know your
likelihood is that you would
you would put them down as a b not not a
c
and so that all adds up in a very very
big system with hundreds of thousands of
students and grades that adds
up to a kind of artificial inflation of
grades which was
what we've heard that the grade
inflation would have been
you know as much as there's been in the
last 20 years if it had if it hadn't
been moderated down
so that's why the grades are different
after the statistical
uh modeling and moderation that the
regulators and exam boards have done
now of course in doing that again
they're
you know applying statistics to uh
you know grades submitted by the centers
and it's not the same
as having an exam paper that's written
by a pupil and that's why these
individual
unfairnesses will um unfortunately have
crept in
it is so unfortunate isn't it and
natasha for these kids who
i mean call them kids they're young
people going off to start their lives
their lives have been
on pause haven't they for so many months
lots of students we've spoken to today
saying it feels so surreal receiving
their results it's been so long since
they've sat in a classroom
um additional pressure on them huge
amount of
uncertainty and this message in um
from susan also a parent asking how she
can best support her child's mental
health
her child was downgraded missed his
place at university and as a parent she
wants to do
her very best by him i mean before i
answer susan's question
i just want to go back to what mary was
saying because
i've long thought that exams aren't
necessarily the best way to measure a
pupils learning
they measure your ability to retain
information and perform well under
pressure which
are two skills within intelligence but
they certainly aren't all-encompassing
and what teachers have done is they have
used their assessment of the grade based
on what a pupil would achieve on their
best day
and that's probably a better and fairer
indication
so the absolute brass neck of an
education secretary
who used to be a fireplace salesman
saying that he's downgraded them because
they might get jobs they aren't
qualified for i can understand why young
people are feeling angry about the
results that they have received today
however um to go to susan's question
what i would say is with parents first
of all when you're feeling anxious on
behalf of your child you'll very often
go to the worst case scenario parents
have really good imaginations
and they'll often assume something worse
is going on with their children than the
reality
so don't try and put your own experience
or
your remembering of what it was like to
be a teenager don't try and project that
onto
what your child is going through because
we are living in completely
unprecedented times
ask him ask him what support he would
like
ask him what you can do lots of open
questions that don't have a yes or no
answer
that won't just give you a better
understanding of what's going on with
him
it's actually been proven that if you
can foster connection
if you can show someone that you're
listening to them non-judgmentally
it actually improves their brain
chemistry so he'll walk away from that
conversation
with better clarity of thought okay
lovely advice there
do please do deborah yes so i mean just
just building on
susan's question natasha's incredibly
important point
i mean if susan's son has missed his
place at university
um again i would say use clearing there
are a huge number of places available in
universities
um so he may not have missed it just
maybe there's an opportunity somewhere
else and i go back to my point about how
we support certainly a range of
universities but certainly brighton how
we support that transition
it's an incredibly important phase in
young people's lives
and and that support is incredibly
incredibly important that journey it's
not just about your academic
learning it's that whole adjustment it's
a huge
phase and a huge step change in young
people's lives so it's incredibly
important that we do that
really well absolutely an hour ago mary
kerner cook we spoke to a selection of
students who got their results today
um one girl we spoke to uh called jenna
who was really disappointed with her
results has decided to
uh defer starting her course until next
year and appeal
let's just have a listen to what she had
to say and i just want to get your
reaction to it afterwards
i was predicted b and two c's but i got
two c's and a d so that is really
disappointing so even though i've got
unconditional offers and i am going
forward to do what i want to do
i think it's unfair that even my
teachers
put down what i was meant to get and
that
it seems like the government and off
call just haven't took that into
consideration and they just made it up
themselves it seems like
it is really unfair i do have a feeling
that it may
have to do with the school that you're
going to or where you're from
exactly maybe because i live in the
north is it different
do i get downgraded or what i don't
think it's fair at all
so mary can it cook echoes the theme of
the previous question that i put to you
but there is so much concern on social
media from
young people that we've been speaking to
that perhaps they might have been
disadvantaged in some way and that's
certainly jenna's feelings
yeah and gosh i i
feel for for jenna um really
you know it must feel it clearly feels
incredibly
unfair to her and but looking at it from
a system point of view
uh you know it it is not personal and
i i think i would encourage her to
consider
um appealing because um
you know the system isn't set up to
disadvantage you know schools in the
north or different types of schools
and there's there's a you know an
important statistical model that's
got lots of data from previous years
that's kind of worked out what the
likely outcomes would have been for
for that school with those with those
students
so i'm sorry to interrupt just is going
to ask just roughly how long do you
think that appeal process would take and
this ties into a question from another
parent sifa
she wants to know if it will be in time
for last minute university places this
year
if kids are appealing so and
and and deborah may know as well but as
i understand it
um universities are asked to keep their
places open until the 7th of september
and the exam boards and offwall will be
trying to prioritize
university applicants who need their
grades for their place
and and have those back by the 7th of
september but i still think there's a
bit of
water to go under the bridge for
everyone to understand exactly how this
is
happening yeah i think we're going to
get a clearer idea aren't we in the next
couple of days from off qual
it kind of ties into the autumn and the
new term let's have a listen to
uh what a prospective medical student
toby was saying to me just an hour ago
um he was very worried about resetting
his exams
in the autumn have a listen to this
deborah humphries
i needed three a's um but i got a bbc
uh so it means that i can't uh get into
uk medical school
um but there may be options
in europe um and i'm not
taking well i might have well i'm gonna
have to take my
autumn exams but the problem is that is
uh quite short
and i haven't really been uh revising
i've been reading medical books and
trying to get in
head of the course so what an
unfortunate set of circumstances for
toby newton his mock exam results were
aab
and he was keeping some gas in the tank
for his summer exams hoping to get all
a's get into medical school and as he
said there he got
bbc and during the pandemic he's been
spending that time revising
the medical course not looking back on
his a levels
um what sort of advice could you give to
him deborah
so um terry don't give up on medicine
it's a
fantastic career it's a demanding course
appeal you've got your mock you know
what your mock results were
um please appeal talk to your university
and as you're saying you're looking at
options in universities in europe
clearly also need to factor in any
impact that brexit may have
um in terms of fees and applications
so appeal talk to the university
think about other options there's lots
of um
available there's lots of options
available it's an incredibly competitive
environment
um but talk to your university talk to
your school
okay good advice um natasha let's uh
play you
a clip from destiny who spoke to us as
well
an hour ago who was talking about her
mental health throughout all of this
in situations like these we do need to
be mentally strong
and um for those that may be you know
really disheartened or demotivated by
this
it's really saddening for for a country
as well that structures so much on
you know individuals mental health it's
actually really sad
since we got on a hold school was shut
down we never asked to be in this
situation
and to be failed or downgraded
on a test that we had never done is
absolutely ridiculous
so let's see what natasha makes that
absolutely ridiculous says destiny
well as i said before i can completely
understand why
destiny is angry and i would urge her to
bear that in mind next time she's called
to go to the ballot box and select who
she votes for very carefully
um i would say however that you know
there are
three quarters of a million a level
students who are all in the same boat
and as we've
already heard throughout this session
today universities are going to be doing
everything they can to take into account
the circumstances that a level students
find themselves
in so again go to student space there's
tips there on
motivating yourself to study from home
if you're worried about the friendship
aspects of university if you're worried
about clearing
it's a one-stop shop for anything that
might be concerning you and remember
something that i always remember myself
in situations where i feel despondent is
something a friend told
me and it's it's only those who stop
kicking
who drown i like that that's a top tip
um this one to you mary will having
coronavirus grades for exams never
actually sat
undermine us when we go for jobs that's
from sophie
i i really don't think so um there's a
sense that
everybody in all walks of life in in
employment
in on the front line people who've been
ill and lost loved ones
let alone students who've been going
through exams
you know everybody's had their lives
affected by coronavirus and i can't
imagine that
um that anybody will do anything more
than
glance at any grades that might be on
somebody's cb
and probably not even notice the date uh
in future years
okay mary kernick cook deborah humphries
and natasha devon thank you all so much
i know lots of people had lots of
questions and thank you so much for
taking the time to answer them we really
appreciate it
well we have more information on what to
do next if you didn't get the grades you
were expecting do head to our website
news.sky.com for more information on the
available options you just need to read
our guide
what to do next scroll down to the
features section of the website
and you'll see it there